do you think we should work to create a
more positive culture
um
not necessarily sex positive
um I don't think it needs to be
um advertised anymore
necessarily by for those who do it it is
what it is but I don't think it needs to
be popularized any further okay so I
should stop tweeting that strippers or
horse
yes
well no it's your opinion but I don't
feel like it need to be I don't think it
needs to be popular I would argue that's
a fact I I would argue that's a fact in
your opinion yeah well we could say
opinion right but then then you look up
the definition of a [__] right it says
prostitution
but you know which you could argue
they're not because they're technically
not having sex or you could argue they
are
because they're taking off their clothes
for money
but that's but it's not tomatoes tomato
like to me
a fact
okay it's still set in six isn't it at
the end of the day
wherever you're actually physically
having sex or visually having sex
still selling sex
so once you sell sex your prostitute
I'm just getting into I'm just saying
technically sexy sex what about you
should we create a more sex positive
culture
I feel like it's already out there
enough I don't think it needs to be
advertised anymore okay like yeah no I
think we definitely do need to create a
more sex positive culture because sex is
natural that's how we're created this
it's something that we can't help but
it's how we
you know cultivate that and get into
that I.E not sleeping with loads of
people that's to the guys as well I've
got young sons and I try to teach them
to be celibate put your energy into your
sports and into your careers and
hopefully when you elevate you can give
yourself to a woman that you know is
decent but also you've got all the STIs
and STDs whatever they're called and the
section like the energy transfer and I
think in that way we need to be more
educated it's not about like oh sex is
bad sex is not bad we're not gonna stop
and I think because we haven't really
taken on face value and be like okay sex
is natural this is why we do have all
the corn and
you know the essay and whatever because
we're restricted and we feel dirty and
it's not like it's natural just find one
person that you Vibes with and you know
build that relationship with them get to
know each other so how would how would
we create a more sex positive culture
I think by educating ourselves a lot
more about it like I think that we need
to really get into this whole thing of
energy it matters you know every person
how should we educate so if you're gonna
are you gonna educate kids are you going
to educate teenagers when do we start
the education yeah I think we should
start the education in schools because
it's normal okay
um I think when puberty starts so like
13 14 yeah yeah so at 14 years old how
do you educate do you tell them how to
have sex no I think you should tell them
about the feeling it's a guide yeah no I
think we should tell them about the
feelings that they're going to
experience you know
um and what they might want to do but I
think we have to educate them on a moral
value to be like look you might have
these feelings and this energy but you
have to kind of hold it within yourself
until you find somebody that you really
connect with and usually don't find that
and so you can pay a bill and so you can
go and if you can't get a job and work
you can't be having sex that's the way I
say to my boy is that if you can't take
a guy on a date and treat a good you
can't be having sex with her and do you
think that's a conversation the schools
should be having or the parents it's a
joint thing it like they say what is it
it takes the is it a village to raise a
child and that's what we need to do
between all of us okay and so you would
tell them not to the message that
education would be telling them don't
have sex until you can have a job
basically yeah okay okay
um what's sex positive what do you say
sex positive should we create a more sex
positive culture no
sex negative yeah
how would you do that Auntie just jumped
out of it didn't they have um in America
somewhere where they have those um
is it celibacy
when they go around the schools and
stuff that's what I grew up getting
that's right and that's it that's the
city speakers that's what they should do
and we had no everyone said okay I had a
certain I'm not gonna name names certain
someone say oh the Catholic schools were
so bad look it I don't know what
Catholic schools you all went to we had
no teen pregnancies in my high school
and we did chat that's what they all
would say oh if you don't have sex ed
you guys are gonna go crazy I'm like no
we're much better than the public
schools I mean there were a lot of
Catholic schools that I knew that are
nearby and
the girls had plenty S6 didn't get
pregnant because they use really good
contraception but they're all Stags
yeah the Catholic girls were the worst
like it that wasn't my high school
wasn't like that it like as my Mom said
that undercover horse
yeah I feel like in
in USA was the public schools they were
just wild in like we didn't even ever
parties or anything with us or if we did
I wasn't invited maybe they had them and
I just wasn't if I don't use that phone
in England that the Catholic girls their
world when they get loose I find that
all girl scores yeah which are normally
yeah yeah England America two different
things that girls are wild yeah I think
in America like they've got real like
what they stand for they stand for they
mean it we're here it's you can just
kind of do what you want to do and
there's no strength in any beliefs
really we don't really have the strong
religious belief where like in America
like they had all those you know groups
and it means something you stand by
something it's your word sure or not
yeah all them data beta clubs in it
um
I read super chats one more time
do you think wait do you think that
changed like that England used to be
like have more of what you were just
talking about yeah cultures standards
when do you think it switched um I think
when the internet was
um blew up and also I think
when we just started integrating
cultures
um I think that's when it kind of just
messed up a little bit because it was
kind of all we all lost our way
basically I think
got it got it
um okay I'm gonna refresh the same Pizza
I think it was
gone and everybody started copying
everybody like the internet opened it up
so everybody started copying America in
here and there ever but I just think
that
it's just they've got too many laws in
England that protect the children
that's what it is you can't do nothing
with your children anymore to protect
them
and I think that's what it is but I
think the internet has got a lot and
just like following other people just
like thinking The Grass Is Always Green
on the other side whatever my mom always
says that
if America gets a cold we sneeze
you know and that's the way it's worked
can I just say as well I think it's like
the drugs and alcohol culture
um because obviously that affects you
and everybody gets all free-minded and
free spirit aired and starts loving
everybody and whatever whatever yeah and
the music because the drugs the drink
the music share it across the world the
media I think that's different I think
in the 70s it was all in the 70s it was
all free love now it's just like sex
drugs I'll [__] everybody yeah but
that's back in the day it was
psychedelic so open it up to your
spiritual self where now it's cocaine
and and MDMA or whatever and that just
messes you up that makes you think it's
something that you're not people don't
even need that to get to get to go on
how they're going yeah well then all the
men need is a it's a good outfit you can
have a good man that looks like a [__]
in the week all the man needs is one
good outfit I said that that we should
do that experiment go and get a [__]
off the streets clean them up get him a
good outfit and hire a car for the day
and just give them like a cup of 100
pounds and go into a club and pick up
any girl he wants Shout and then let him
turn up the next day how he normally
looks
and then nobody's gonna want it because
that's all it takes it's a good outfit
and a car how often a minute did they
hire the cars anyway they don't belong
to them they're just getting free sex
you know for a lift home you know you
think it's that easy for guys yeah it is
we should do it I think it's that easy
for a guy to go and get it because women
nowadays they're so loose and all they
care about is you got there seriously
get a guy put chain on him and get him
some name brand clothes and all that
belugiana or whatever their name is I
give him a car you know and turn them
outside a nightclub guaranteed put him
on the table with a great big bottle of
champagne as well with some other men
that look like him the girls are gonna
Rush him
I don't know I went okay so I probably
would have thought like that I went to
him you guys know what pickup is so
pickup is basically where men learn how
to get laid okay so you know it started
with and I'm probably gonna butcher this
a little bit sorry chat but there's
certain guys that really like pickup
artist so it's called Neil Strauss the
game and it was him dealing with these
guys that basically teach other men how
to get laid there's videos on YouTube so
like for example
one thing they would teach which is a
bit more PG is to make sure to touch the
girl not in like a weird way but how are
you going to go home with a guy if he
hasn't touched you all night like have
you ever heard a guy try to take you
home and like you literally haven't
touched once the whole day like how are
you gonna feel comfortable okay
that's a PG version so I when I was
doing research on this channel I went to
a pickup boot camp and these guys would
pay
thousands of dollars to be taught for a
weekend how to get laid Sims
look I'm not gonna look but here's the
thing Andy they were more normal I mean
well it was a wide variety but some of
them were more normal than you thought
that would like and it kind of put me in
the men's point of view because you know
you're kind of helping them you're like
oh go up to that girl or go up to that
girl and I could not believe like how
harsh girls were to these guys like even
if they had a nice suit on or they I
would say like some of them were better
looking than the girls like they would
they would reject them so harshly you
know why because anybody any man that
pays a couple of grand for that ain't
got that ain't got the patter and that's
a talk to a girl the girl just wants to
wear all that [__] talk the smooth talk
that the men do and that's what they're
missing yeah so it's like how do you how
do they change their personalities even
even if even if you get the suit and put
them in VIP then yeah you can't like one
guy talked to me about domination yeah
he was gonna like be a conqueror
he's gonna like conquer the world I was
like what I'll bet he's one of those
that go and dress up in army costumes
and playing fields at the end of the
week auntie I don't know you know you
should go to um
um was it erotica Expo they do that they
do an expo we're very Frank erotic and
they do classes in there you want me to
go to that I'll take you
go together I'll find out where it is
wait I'll find it blow your mind what
would it what would I do there no is it
is this like a great big um you know how
you have a Comic-Con Comic-Con
Expedition yeah and then you have a
erotica Expedition
um
okay I'm gonna get put a cage and hang
out from the ceiling I would rather not
do that okay
um reclaim your throne my rose son found
out he's embarrassed around his peers of
girls are narcissists who sacrifice
their children's mental health for
pleasure and money absolutely apparent
um
western western hose are zinc dumps
nothing more EIP jungulin um stop trying
to change hoes we need hoes for the
world to go around men need recreational
use or men that aren't ready will have
to commit in order to get some action
whose side are you on
you're right my bad my bad
um Taylor uh men have to have a contract
to provide support and offer ourselves
um for our family women have their side
of the contract when this breaks down
the family breaks down um Society breaks
down the clue Channel
um the U.S must have a really good
publicist in the UK standards are a
thing of the past here I'm NSX Pearl
your analogies have been on point lately
great stuff lazy Prodigy with all due
respect I'm worried for all men raised
with modern women they will be more
feminine versus masculine I'm culture
find men become less sexually attracted
to a woman a day to a woman the longer
they are with her the Coolidge effect
scientifically confirmed oh that's
interesting
a less okay
um Dylan Pearl do you have plans to head
to Vegas and talk to Rolo I saw Rolo's
episode on about sauce cast not reading
super chats and you and Rolo were going
at it in the chat
um no
um
you know I did try that once and I I
just wasted some money and time so I'd
rather not you know
do that again
um
Cayenne gray can you explain what a 304
means for the chat
um Sylvester Gooding paid for sex at
least here safe in regards to getting an
STD you actually get sex so that is a
guarantee um culture fine if you want to
oh I read that one already let me just
refresh the chat really quick
um
okay
I'm surprised at those super [__] it's
all done what do you mean you're
surprised oh they're being nicer mean
yeah they're being good it's been nice
I know I sometimes if I skipped any no I
haven't I look I I like to read them
because they pay for them but sometimes
I'd like to read your sometimes
I have really horrible ones
okay do you guys think that if a girl is
a single mother that the man and the
women are equally responsible
what do you mean so if a woman's a
single mother who's responsible the man
or the woman
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible